i don't know many people who don't
really like food but i really liked food
i really do think part of it was because
of the medication i was taking i think
ssris can really increase hunger in
people and i was on them since i was 12.
and i noticed when i stopped them that
that really lessened so i think part of
it was that but i really enjoyed what i
ate and i can remember traveling and
being like oh i wonder what kind of food
is there but it was like part of the
experience while traveling but then when
i like switched over and cut everything
that i considered really palatable out
of my diet because of the arthritis and
among many other things it really
changed how i viewed traveling it really
did because i was like it doesn't matter
where i go i'm going to be eating at
steak houses that's not bad right if you
have to eat at one restaurant a
steakhouse isn't that bad a place to
have to eat but it does remove an aspect
of traveling which is it's kind of sad
but it's also kind of freeing in a way